by order of the overseer council the
following file describes a counter-class
anomalous cognitohazard and is level 4
2316 classified unauthorized access is
forbidden
item number
2316
level 4 secret containment class ketter
disruption class canic
and risk class
danger
the following file contains images and
texts that are carriers for anomalous
cognito hazardous influences
you do not recognize the bodies in the
water
due to this it is imperative that all
personnel accessing this file be
certified as having a cognitive
resistance value crv of no less than
14.5
should you fail an automated crv
verification please remain calm and do
not move
a member of your site's medical staff
will be with you shortly
please repeat the following phrase
slowly and clearly into your terminal
microphone
running it just a tonal variance
processor
verification complete user crv is within
acceptable limits
special containment procedures
under no circumstances are foundation
personnel to approach scp-2316
observation of
scp-2316 must only be carried out by
remote dummy probes utilizing video and
audio recording equipment only those
personnel adequately rated for exposure
to cognito hazardous anomalies may
review footage and audio of scp-2316
the lake in which
scp-2316 is located has been quarantined
and fenced off and is to be routinely
patrolled by individuals who have not
been exposed to scp-2316
and have no prior knowledge of its
characteristics
individuals who attempt to bypass the
enforced quarantine must be apprehended
and moved to site-33 for a full
cognitive influence screening
individuals who come within 50 meters of
the lake containing scp-2316
are to be considered lost
repeat the following phrase slowly and
clearly into your terminal microphone
running in just a tonal variance
processor
verification complete user crv is within
acceptable limits
description
scp-2316 is the designation for an
anomalous phenomenon existing within
lake
within
county
scp-2316
manifests as a group of human corpses
floating in a small group at the surface
of the water the identities of these
corpses are
removed
unknown though dna testing has been
inconclusive
while
scp-2316 appears to be individual
instances it is theorized that
scp-2316 may instead be an entity
composed of a collective consciousness
individual instances of
scp-2316 do not act on their own but do
seem to be able to act collectively as a
single unit the individual instances of
scp-2316 are unrecognizable
scp-2316 hosts a powerful
cognitohazardous effect causing those
who have viewed scp-2316
are aware of certain parts of its nature
or who were enrolled in
invalid to believe that the individual
instances of
scp-2316 are human beings they recognize
typically from their childhood
attempting to come into contact with
scp-2316 instances by way of entering
like
or touching an instance of scp-2360
will cause other instances of
scp-2316 to appear
the additional instances only serve to
reinforce and add to the strength of the
cognato hazard compelling affected
individuals into the lake individuals
who enter the lake in this way are lost
and to date none have been recovered
addendum 2316
1
interview
did you ever feel compelled to enter the
water like something was pulling you in
what no of course not there's nothing
wrong with them they didn't drag me in
i saw them in the water and went in
myself i needed to see them i wanted to
hear what they were saying
they're my friends
when you entered
what did you see faces my friends faces
i recognized
so i didn't but they became more
familiar as i saw them i'd known them my
whole life but there was something wrong
with something wrong with them like the
face of someone you see in a dream or
you can't remember it right
there's something wrong and the way
they're speaking they speak
no that's impossible they're simply not
moving their mouths but i could hear
them
asking for help
they told me they told me who they were
they told me you knew who they were that
you
the
you're
clearly
it we need to get you medical attention
agent if you put your hands off me i
know all their names harrison i heard
them speaking to me every single one all
it takes is one person to see the patel
people and they'll know what you'll be
trying to hide target would i scope you
awesome get them out of here take them
to amnestics and turn that goddamn
recorder on log
please repeat the following free slowly
and clearly into your terminal
microphone
medical staff
addendum 23 16 2.
below into the water look into their
eyes
it's your friends your classmates you
took the trip to the lake in the fall of
75 together when you were young don't
you remember look into their eyes i know
you can hear them talking to you just
like they talk to me don't let them tell
you it's just a cognitive hazard this is
their fault
they caused this
we were all innocent kids don't you
remember and you just got away you and i
the rest of them are at the bottom of
that lake waiting for us to go back to
them and be whole together again
they want us to know they want us to
wake up god damn it remember the fall of
75 the year we were supposed to graduate
don't let them make you forget
they're calling to you can you hear them
can you hear
them can you hear them
can you hear them
can you hear them can't you hear them
can you hear them
look into their eyes
can you hear them can't you hear them
can't you hear them can you hear them
can you hear them can't you hear them
can you hear them can you hear them
[Music]
they're waiting for you
description
scp-1833 is a copy of the 1976 edition
kirkland wood high school yearbook
previously belonging to student carolyn
kirk
the yearbook shows mild wear and use
indicative of its age
the front cover of scp-1833
shows a arrow design
with the words reflections of 76 near
the center of the page
and klhs
1976 in the bottom right corner
the back of
scp-1833 is blank
say for a small amount of charring along
the spine
an inscription inside the back cover
reads
we've had a great year haven't we
don't worry about waiting for the
reunion
i'm sure we'll see each other soon
enough
lots of love
from all your best friends
verification complete user crv is within
acceptable limits
i would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
professor puffer
the morrigan
retalias
karim el ashmuy
jaby
pure osmium
sayo diodemnatus
revenant
brian sanchez
matthew gilmore
eric corbage
kawaii fire keeper
longinus
carcass death aqua
king madding
james saba and
nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash thevogen
thank you
you